we're asked to solve the right triangle
shown below give the lengths to the
nearest tenth so when they say solve the
right triangle we can assume that
they're saying hey figure out the
lengths of all the sides so whatever a
is equal to whatever b is equal to and
also what are all the angles of the
right triangle we get they've given two
of them we might have to figure out this
third right over here
so there's multiple ways to tackle this
but we'll just go and we'll just try to
tackle side x w first try to figure out
what a is and i'll give you a hint you
can use a calculator and using a
calculator you can use your
trigonometric functions that we've
looked at a good bit now so i'll give
you a few seconds to think about how to
figure out what a is
well what do we know we know this angle
y right over here we know the side
adjacent to angle y and length a this is
the side that's the length of the side
that is opposite that is opposite to
angle y
so what trigonometric ratio what
trigonometric ratio deals with the
opposite and the adjacent so if we're
looking at angle y relative to angle y
this is the opposite
and this right over here is the adjacent
well if we don't remember we can go back
to sohcahtoa
sine deals with opposite and hypotenuse
cosine deals with adjacent and
hypotenuse tangent deals with opposite
over adjacent opposite over adjacent so
we can say that the tangent
the tangent
of 65 degrees
of that angle of 65 degrees is equal to
the opposite the length of the opposite
side which we know has length a
over the length of the adjacent side
which they gave us in the diagram which
has length which has length 5. and you
might say well how do i figure out a
well we can use our calculator to
evaluate what the tangent of 65 degrees
are and then we can solve for a and
actually if we just want to get the
expression
explicitly solving for a we can just
multiply both sides of this equation
times five so let's do that
five times
times five these cancel out and we are
left with if we flip the the equal
around we're left with a is equal to
five times the tangent
of 65
of 65 degrees so now we can get our
calculator out and figure out what this
is to the nearest tenth
i get my handy ti-85 out
and i have five times
the not
the tangent no i i didn't need to press
that second right over there just the
regular tangent of 65 degrees
and i am like i get
if i round to the nearest tenth like
they ask me to i get 10.7
so this is so a
is approximately equal to 10.7 i say
approximately because i rounded it i
rounded it down i didn't this is not the
exact number but a is equal to 10.7 so
we now know that this has length 10.7
approximately
there's several ways that we can try to
tackle b and i'll let you pick the way
you want to but then i'll just do it the
way i would like to so my next question
to you is
what is the length of the side y w or
what is the value of b
well there's several ways to do it this
is a hypotenuse so we could use
trigonometric functions that deal with
adjacent over hypotenuse or opposite
over hypotenuse or we could just use the
pythagorean theorem we know two sides of
a right triangle we can come up with the
third side
i will go with i will go with using
trigonometric ratios since that's what
we've been working on a good bit so this
length b that's the length of the
hypotenuse
so this
side wi is
the hypotenuse
and so what trigonometric ratios and we
can decide what we want to use we could
use opposite and hypotenuse we could use
adjacent and hypotenuse
since we know that xy is exactly five
and we don't have to deal with this
approximation let's use that side so
what trigonometric ratios deal with
adjacent and hypotenuse
well we see from sohcahtoa cosine deals
with adjacent over hypotenuse so we
could say that the cosine of 65 degrees
cosine of 65 degrees is equal to the
length of the adjacent side which is 5
over the length of the hypotenuse which
has
length b
and then we can try to solve for b you
multiply both sides times b you're left
with b times cosine of 65 degrees is
equal to 5 and then to solve for b you
could divide both sides by cosine of 65
degrees
this is just a number here so we're just
dividing we have to figure it out with
our calculator but this is just going to
evaluate to some number so we can divide
both sides by that by cosine of 65
degrees
cosine of 65 degrees and we're left with
b
is equal to 5 over the cosine of 65
degrees so let us now use our calculator
to figure out the length of b length of
b is 5 divided by
cosine of 65 degrees
and i get if i round to the nearest
tenth 11.8
so b
is approximately equal to rounded to the
nearest tenth
11.8 so b is equal to
11.8 and then we're almost done solving
this right triangle and you could have
figured this out using the pythagorean
theorem as well saying that 5 squared
plus 10.7 squared should be equal to b
squared and hopefully you would get the
exact same answer and the last thing we
have to figure out is the measure of
angle w
angle w right over here so i'll give you
a few seconds to think about what the
measure of angle w is
well here we just have to remember that
the sum of the angles of a triangle add
up to 180 degrees so
angle w
plus 65 degrees that's this angle right
up here plus the right angle this is a
right triangle they're going to add up
to 180 degrees so all we need to do is
well we could simplify the left hand
side right over here 65 plus 90 is 155
so angle w plus
155 degrees is equal to 180 degrees and
then we get angle w if we subtract 155
from both sides angle w is equal to
25 degrees
and we are done
solving the right triangle shown below